on retrouve natacha fait d'aurillac à
ukrainienne est professeur de français
habitant de karkhiv la seconde ville du
pays bonjour quelle est la situation
autour de vous et dans la ville de
kharkiv tout d'abord la filmant
s'essayer au centre-ville de car qui va
on attend des courges et ce parce que
c'est exactement mais alors des gares
des explosions et alors il parait qu'il
ya déjà des chars russes et des
militaires russes au centre ville de
kharkiv et alors là il est interdit à
tout le monde de sortir du dehors et
alors c'est gagné alerte on va descendre
au sol avec avec les enfants mais c'est
ce qu'on fait depuis quatre jours déjà
alors plusieurs fois par jour en
baissant pour protéger les enfants quels
sentiments des habitants de karkhiv
eux mais on a peur on a vraiment peur
c'est effrayant parce qu'on aurait pu
vraiment imaginer une chose pareille à
un 21e siècle alors c'est vraiment une
guerre une guerre qu'on a vu tout ça
dans les films mais par contre alors
même on dit que si mme on est russophone
ici mais nous craignent un et alors on
est patriote est ce qui est ce que vous
savez s'il ya eu des civils blessés ou
tués oui il ya eu des civils ce matin il
ya
c'est pas un
obus qui a
touché une maison un immeuble et il y
avait déjà une femme qui est morte mais
à leur part ont dit que il y en a pas
mal c'est ce que je t'aimais
et quelles étaient les cibles là
actuellement des bombardements d
attaques
mais les cibles alors la carte c'est une
grande ville industrielle
il ya beaucoup d' usine et à l'arrière
hier et entière bombarder les usines les
usines d avion lusine des chars lu ting
détracteurs alors en fait toutes les
ultimes sont bombardés en plus il ya des
stations d'essence qui brûle elle voit
là et alors je crois est alors les
installations militaires aussi les
opérations militaires sont aussi
bombardé même si c'est c'est pas parfois
parfois ça se trouve dans les quartiers
des gens habitent et bien sûr que non
les civils sont aussi touchés et vous
parlez du sentiment patriotique est ce
qu'il ya un sentiment patriotique fort
dans la ville de kharkiv mais alors
parmi mes amis oui
mais je peux pas je peux pas vraiment
dire que le monde mais parmi mes amis de
mon départ et patriotique en tête c'est
vraiment c'était vraiment affreuse qui
se passe est alors de 13,7 en pays
européens quand même et c'est un grand
pays et c'est pas possible de franchir
les frontières d'un pays comme ça d'une
manière agressive et en plus d'amener
les
les militaires de tirer je sais bien sûr
les forces armées ukrainiennes
l'instant il ya une mobilisation dans ce
cas contre les troupes russes est ce
qu'il ya une mobilisation compter
troupes russes oh oui oui et à beaucoup
de volontaires de volontaires qui ont
pris les armes pour protéger de la ville
il ya des hommes jeunes qui s'engagent
pour défendre le pays actuellement qu'au
café tout à fait et ils sont nombreux
d'après vous oui
merci beaucoup natacha fait d'aurillac à
d'avoir été avec nous sur france24 merci
à vous pour votre témoignage